hello and welcome
to this video yeah this is chapter 8 of
our course on how to fight you form like
Khurana chapter 8 deals again with the
proper petrov so we have these darling
moves and now what we're going to look
at is the following why taking only five
and after this sequence we will examine
the move deform this was the undisputed
main line of the whole petrov for a very
long time
basically yeah up until maybe 10 to 15
years ago when people started to employ
Knight c3 more regularly and I think by
now we can safely say that this is yeah
this has all the right to be called the
main line and not d4 anymore but okay
this is a technicality what you call
main line new main line or maid line
I've labeled this the old main line
because I perceive that 93 is yeah more
popular nowadays and also I feel sets
and more difficult problems for black so
d4 is of course the most natural move
ever white wants to develop with Bishop
d3 we play d5 of course as Adam it's
typical in this opening and now it's a
thing quite interesting to ya think
about this term this is position in a
more general term that it is a
symmetrical pawn structure in the center
and in fact it is the same pawn
structure as we get in an exchange
French with the open e file the real
yeah coming thing about this is that
black is actually in some way ahead in
development it's like it was symmetrical
and then black played Knight to e4 I
could imagine that it is a completely
symmetrical position and Blake's last
move was Knight to e4
so what white does in this line or wants
to prove in this line is that this night
is more of a liability than a strength
this is some calm
theme of course we have seen something
similar also in the line starting with
3d form but yeah it is very very
pronounced white well basically based on
its plane that well all the play that is
in some way ambitious yeah what can also
do like just nothing and don't pose any
problem but everything that is going to
be a threat in some way to Black's game
will be related to trying to attack the
knight trying to attack d5 with c4
somehow trying to prove that this night
is prematurely somehow placed one let's
say unstable placed only form so let's
get going with some moves white now goes
Bishop e3 this is the absolute main line
and super logical we should briefly
check what else white has tried white
also has tried the immediate c4 this is
I have a quite obviously not so
challenging because that check looks
good and it's good for black after a
sequence like that white already has to
worry about being equal something like
this for example it's just excellent for
black yeah we have all those pins going
on and yeah white is in trouble after
very short time in the game very rarely
seen also Bishop e2 it's really rather
pointless to have it here instead of d3
I mean it would break a pin that is not
yet there but not the most logical move
it's just that I think you should just
play it like as we do in the mainline go
Bishop d6 and do something like that if
you compare that to the bishop being on
d3 yeah well it's just a more passive
version as I mentioned the pressure
against d5 is the is a key element to
whites play and almost the only element
so here this is not not really happening
so Bishop d3 is the main line by a miles
and here in fact is a very important
pardon of the ways where black now is
able to choose the line this is
something that I always feel is quite
quite
suitable if in key situations you are
the one determining how the plane is
going to continue I will go right away
and show you what we're going to play
what our recommendation is Bishop to d6
this is also what Khurana has played all
the time he has not really varied in any
way they always played Bishop d6 which
is an interesting choice it is not it
was not the main line up to some years
ago but Khurana has done an excellent
job of yeah showing how great blacks
resources are in this line I'd like to
mention that there are many alternatives
here so once you have mastered Bishop d6
it would be quite easy to add something
else to a repertoire what I want to
mention in particular is a line that
I've played myself in games and that is
Bishop to e7 castles and Bishop f5
aligned that is had not yet has a name
but it would be probably appropriate to
call it the Chinese wards it's how I
coined it it is a line that is played by
I think almost all of the Chinese top
players from from dinging - yeah
whatever I am one you and so on here
they all play this line you yang ye it's
um it's they seem to have work as a team
on that and the particular line there is
very very solid alternative it's a very
different line because here black does
not try to with what he does with Bishop
e6 yeah triangle tries not to display
the utmost activity and but here black
is warm out to neutralize white in but
ideas like this I just wanted to mention
that this is a good alternative also
sometimes it happened to me that people
look in databases and they then they
send me a message like you recommend
that move but you played something else
and I played in fact this line earlier
in 2018 in an important game at the time
I did not yet started this
zot this project here on the Caruana
repertoire so I never looked at Bishop
d6 at that particular moment so it was
not a choice between the two
I only later learned how Bishop d6 works
so let's look at this Bishop to d6 yeah
black chooses the most active square for
the bishop quite clear Nia that is the
most active square and really says okay
I'm not going to give you any ground I'm
just trying to be as active as possible
and trying to prove that my knight is
not a problem only forward rather an
asset here white castles has renamed not
much else
white can try to play c4 immediately and
the only thing that I wanted to show is
that the tempting looking move Bishop
before check it's not really that great
I was surprised to see that but what can
even play king of one and it is not that
clear
so my suggestion is to simply cancel
here if after c4 and say okay why do you
don't have anything better than castle
in yourself which is the transposition
to the mainline and I think this is
probably true the alternatives don't
really convince at all if white for
example takes then the check makes a lot
more sense as now the center is opened
immediately and something something like
that it's just comfortable for black
white also may play c5 after which we of
course drop back no other Square and
then play like this is very logical we
can attack this pawn and white some yeah
expansion here didn't really net
anything we can also go here at the
later stage this is very fine c4 already
is a rather obscure move I just wanted
to point out that the immediate Bishop
b4 check it's not yeah it's not really
that promising by the way just so show a
difference like here King f1 is less of
an issue because the centre is open and
there is no c5 threat yeah if you
imagine this him might would even
threaten this and make this bishop look
a bit silly so we have to see a
difference there again c4 is rather
obscure I just want to point out though
give the check immediately so wide
usually castles and we castle and now
here the only testing plan for white
really is to move c4 now by far the main
move or maybe white can flick in rupee
one and then place it form that's the
only thing that poses any sort of
problem if white plays slowly and we
will look at two two examples that kind
of the same now the white is playing in
a passive way we have no problem at all
but I would like to point out that this
is happening really in games people
don't always play c4 particularly
particularly not if you are playing like
in a regular girl in a club game or in a
league game that is not yeah the first
leak and any any country people will
sometimes just not play the main lines
that are challenging but play something
else and here this is for example
extremely comfortable for black already
we keep the e4 Knight and this Knight is
a nuisance it's just a strong piece here
white doesn't have enough pressure and
note here it's already too late for any
c4 action because if you enjoyed the
free video preview make sure to go to
chesterlaw.com slash fight like a
Khurana to get to the full course the
full course with the move trainer and
video sync technology is an excellent
way to learn all the ideas and
strategies connected to this repertoire
these lines were essential in kiwanis
fight to get the world title match and
they can be an essential part of your
opening repertoire as well
you